memphis in the lower
third and there is a great interception
breaking up but two on one melton oh
look at the rats
hold on
buckle up and close your eyes indeed and
here's morant coming in this dunk oh
something else
that is a mid-season dunk right
tyler
missing that shot between a lob and a
mid-range
ball nice pass bridge is able to score a
young leader whose game is coming around
and this man already forces no sleight
of hand big make by bane gives him the
gooseneck got to get back marketing
going long
a sensational skyscraper block jared for
three
nearly banked it in
look at this that's amazing
with the left hand again making sure
look at this top of the box had to avoid
the backboard
mobley oh smothered by jaron loose ball
picked up by the grizzlies melted
lob
[Applause]
baby oh my goodness
goodness i thought melton had thrown
this and no way could get it
morant again catches it
watch this he's behind him he catches it
partner throws it down full extension by
morass timeout cavaliers
in this lineup westbrook and lebron
james will find their teammates morant
working through a double team wow finds
adams underneath what a pass by marantz
[Applause]
they thought they had them bottled up
has been a strength of the grizzlies
along with john miranda and his ability
to create
this and the inside throw it down
outlets to moran
[Applause]
[Music]
just special
he's underneath the basket on the other
side still able to finish the english
that he's able to put on his basketball
barn he's coming down the english on the
ball around and schroeder beats williams
good challenge by plumley that's what he
brings to this year's club
bridges oh my godness runs it down with
the right hand
dude look at this pass right here left
hand over the head bosses who's that two
it's to zero punch it in
[Applause]
he's a game shooter though i watch you
warm up every game he doesn't like that
warm-up look at
that touchdown
75 feet to gordon hayward get a rebound
is everybody sleeping how perfect is
that pass full win
here's hayward
his second season after signing in 120
million dollar deal paul spins it in as
he got around carter for two
he's doing anything he wants it and
watch
the ball con
[Applause]
claxton switched on ball here ball
looking to take claxton off the window
and in lamelo ball beautifully done good
way to get it started
he's got a big smile on his face
ball answers with a three
mellow ball james johnson on the floor
for brooklyn
durant starts the quarter on the bench
blackstone back in and again
playing at a quicker pace
ball floats it in
lamella ball
yeah that was such a point of emphasis
for steve nash before the game sarah
talked about it as paul flips it in
plus the foul
lamelo ball a chance for three
once again
going to his right
gets in the paint the bump
and one
[Music]
noble rookie out of usc here's morant
going strong to the rack took the hit
finished anyway over marketing
we'll see here with morant
defended by an excellent one-on-one
defender able to get by
garland
big jump ahead in his shooting
percentage last year to this and marantz
morat who was on fire in the preseason
but two guys that can still help this
team win basketball games oh look at
this jump off play to miranda oh that is
so well done
russell stephen adams great testimony
the eye contact between the two stephen
adams lets him know to run down the
court knew that he was going to be
a big physical bruiser from day one he
took nothing off of anybody marine
exploding to the rack
[Applause]
transferring from one big to another i
thought it was great with oh nice cut
oh wow
grizzlies were so good
on baseline out of bounds jb bickerstaff
coaching here in memphis there's job
right down the lane
their pick-and-roll defense tonight has
been carved up
by john marin
to draw within nine after trailing by
16. and it just won't go away morant
against marking in scoops and scores
killers
as a player he's going to do a little
bit of everything and as he gets older
they'll be able to maximize more of
those things
[Applause]
[Music]
probing dribble teardrop got the bounce
knocking down floaters that one was just
a minute ago this was a couple of
possessions cleveland hasn't led since
it was 36-35 early second quarter
jb has decided to size down and match up
with the grizzlies not stay with a big
lineup morant
yes and finishing possession with
rebounds as morant on two half court
sets has done a great job of him to this
point to have the confidence and know
where he wants to get you on the floor
two floaters and now knocks down
uber layup is the first time he touched
it
one man
[Applause]
right here perfect textbook defense get
it with your outside hand
[Applause]
lamelo
[Applause]
six
quickly look them all
with a dribble in the eyes pull them up
three just set him up so nicely
to get a good look
third
second quarter triple for lavello
[Applause]
deflections that keep track of that
saves it
rookie the excellent play ubrey could
have forced a shot right there he said
no we got good momentum
where's my point guard halfway through
our third quarter
[Applause]
this guy
loves to play the game
let's play under the screen holiday
that's a mistake easy
knock that one in and hold the follow
through
[Applause]
[Music]
lavello
just in case you forgot
number two was in the game
oh let it be known
gotta call someone's name with duarte
and he has come through
[Applause]
look at that pass
and
as long as that ball is online when
you're at the top it's too
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of don't like this a lot except
when i'm at home on my couch watching
them doing against other teams but
outstanding patience
right here and it's tough not to go for
that ball fake even though my goodness
athleticism is off the
charts
you know getting opportunities just like
this okay to drive down the lane and
then the late slip by adams
once she gets down the lane john moran
he's gonna look to pass set up his guys
if he doesn't have the shot and that
time the late rotation
the grizzlies have the lead but the
clippers have the momentum
[Music]
[Applause]
just glide to the basket at ease and
that time terence man if you get up too
high and making a nice shot with the
defender retreated just two or three
steps
vent play
ricky had a double double in his
cavalier debut ball fires and scores
bridges lost his balance lifted off the
window here from the cavs with numbers
that pass though broken outfits sexton
tried to find jenny osmond ball
underneath
got to get some stops dig in play
defense that can really ignite you if
you just stop
stop it once or twice
and then kind of letting things get away
from them now turnovers were a problem
for the cavaliers throughout the
pre-season in the opener in memphis they
coughed it up only 11 times which was a
good sign ball no looks it passed the
hayward at the corner
and the hornets continue to roll here on
the fourth so does denzel valve die the
former goal there's taco with the
rebound
taco got stripped from behind by ball
[Applause]
a lot of rebounds away from him during
their time in oklahoma city
morant who's becoming a much better
three-point shooter lebron behind the
break back hangs he gets blocked
rejected three on three miranda middle
miranda right now
slam dunk
what the griers want to do though get
out and run and show off those young
legs clark look at that trampoline act
gets to pass for the job
the anthony melton
and there's john morant rising and
throwing it down with one hand
underneath too strong but adams cleans
it up and misses blew the layup got
another one under the milan
over and around a.d that time to score
that wasn't an easy shot not at all
[Applause]
oh he goes around the double and throws
it down with two hands
[Applause]
another look at
moran going between two defenders and
getting on his trampoline two and a half
to play in the third quarter we're
knotted up at 83. moran quickly spinning
shooting scoring
putting on a show isn't he
[Applause]
brought to you by morongo casino resort
and spa
[Music]
as morant with the left hand smooth play
35 minutes lebron going to the rim again
again he doesn't get the call dude they
go back the other way it's moran taking
on the entire laker team
[Applause]